هنا هنا
[موسيقى]
329. هل يمكنك النزول إلى هنا نحتاج إلى المساعدة ،
لقد حصلنا على شخص ما تحت هذا
الحطام
في حوض الاستحمام ،
نحن نبحث عن 15 شهرًا
يا رضيع
[موسيقى]
حسنًا
[موسيقى
] شعرت بالصدمة  شعرت
بهز المنزل ،
الشيء التالي الذي علمت أن الحوض قد
رفع ولم أستطع
التمسك بيدي فقط يا إلهي كنت أبحث في
كل مكان لأرى أين قد يكون الحوض
ليس لدي أدنى فكرة عنه
كل ما يمكنني قوله هو الرب ، يرجى
إعادة أطفالي إلي بأمان ، من فضلك أتوسل
إليكما كلاهما بخير ، الحمد لله ، يا رب
يسوع ،
شكرًا لك يا يسوع ، فقط ركب السيارة
معه ، واجعله يجف
جيدًا وانظر هنا  ها هو الطفل الصغير
الذي أخبرتك أنني سأحصل عليه ،
لقد سمعت للتو صوت ما بدا
وكأنه بكاء أو صراخ
قادم من بعيد ، والأفعال
التي اتخذتها الجدة بداخلك ،
تعلمون وضع البطانيات
والوسائد
كل تلك الأشياء حولها  هؤلاء الأطفال الذين
أعتقد أنهم ربما كانوا يعرفون ما
الذي جعل  فرقك